of the prime minister
and
is completely unacceptable
and really an utter disgrace
what was was may 2020 like for you
may 2020s i have very very vivid
memories
um because it's the month that i've
buried my father and
we
we were restricted in numbers we had a
few people around the graveside
um as we said goodbye to my dad
and um you know we we made many
sacrifices
i
wasn't able to be with my father and
died
um i wasn't able to to visit him
um
in the care home where he was
uh we we had to stand outside the window
and speak to him
um and these were you know in in his
final days so
um you know there are some very painful
memories there really from around that
time
um we buried him on 15th of may
um at that time clearly the
the downing street party was uh was
being planned for that time
and
you know we weren't able to give
my father
the send off but he would have lied he
was a religious man
and
he would love to have had a congregation
in a church
singing his favorite hymns
you know that's what he wanted
told that you know thanks very much gene
let's bring in let's bring in kate
pickett and
kate you run a beauty salon how how
strictly did you stick to the rules and
and what impact did it have on you
um i mean we we stopped them all the way
through we um
we worked out actually in the last
couple of months that we were closed for
47 weeks in total
um obviously starting from march um 2020
um and obviously the last one ending
last august so
we had 26 girls um
who were out of work and at the time
actually um about 80 of those were
self-employed with no financial support
um
so yeah you know it it was so hard for
everyone and we'd only been open 18
months we were running successfully we'd
won lots of awards um but you know being
a new business we didn't have that
financial support or cushion um
to see us through um the government
funding was was so little um and with
kind of the rent still being asked
yeah it was a real struggle and
obviously i thought you know my business
was going to close
so yeah it was a really really tough
time i mean as a business owner and also
as a mother i was just going to say
meanwhile you've got kids as well
haven't you so you would having to
manage home schooling as part of this
how did that go yeah so i had
uh i had two children off um one who
suffers very badly with separation
anxiety actually
so obviously i think in total they had
about seven
six or seven months off uh my husband
was lucky to still be at work um but
also that meant i was at home doing it
on my own
um and you know the frustration for the
children you know not not not being at
school and not being able to see their
friends
um this is why this makes it even more
infuriating you know that you know my
daughter's had to have some counselling
um to support her mental health around
you know that that period of education
that she missed out on and you know that
that those relationships with our peers
so
yeah it's it's infuriating as a mother
and a business owner to to see what
they've been up to
nina nina ambrose uh let's talk to you
now you you volunteered uh during the
lockdown in a care home the care home
where you'd lost your dad very very
sadly paint us a picture of what your
may 2020 was like
yeah dad had moved into a home in
january 2020 so we had a couple of
months to get used to it and the care
home went into lockdown
just slightly earlier than the um uk
went into lockdown and i just said look
i will do anything anything at all to
see my dad i will cook i will clean i'll
do whatever so
luckily i was put on furlough
um and i did end up volunteering at
dad's care home so that i was able
to see him during these times and
listen i i
i really do think that i was lucky
during that time because so many people
were not able to see their loved ones
and working in the care home i saw the
lengths that people went to to be able
to just get a glimpse of their loved
ones during that time what was it what
was life like in the care home in terms
of the lockdown regulations how
difficult was it doing doing your job
you know
it was very difficult it's the carers
that i really felt for they were doing
longer hours they were having to wear
masks obviously there was a lot more
residents within the care home because
usually you know loved ones would come
and take
uh sorry relations would come and take
their loved ones out so
you know in in
in a a care home where there's 100
residents at any one time before there
would probably be you know 60 70 say
so
throughout those whole months all the
residents were in the care home so the
care staff were having to work even
harder under difficult circumstances
that's really really hard isn't it um
okay back back to you if there was
another lockdown now
and boris johnson said right these are
the regulations this is how it's going
to affect your business what would your
thoughts be
i mean i've already preempted this i was
thinking this back in december actually
and
it was kind of a double-edged sword
because
i most certainly wouldn't want to lock
down um
and that you know that's really hard for
me as a business owner because obviously
you know it is out there it's dangerous
you know people have lost loved ones but
also you know i nearly lost everything
as did you know 26 other girls
including like you know my state of
mental well-being as well and so
in light of what's happened i i
certainly wouldn't be looking to to lock
down and
obviously i would try and stand my
ground as long as you know we operate
with full ppe
um i think that you know
i would be liable for a fine but but
likewise you know are they being fined
and it just seems it's one more for one
and one more for another so yeah i would
be
on the on the side of not looking down
and campaigning and standing up standing
up for my business
nodding away at the one rule for one and
one rule for another saying absolutely
and gene kate and nina thank you so much
for for talking to us you're going to
stay with us and we're going to speak to
you just before prime minister's
questions because we want to hear from
you then what you're hoping to hear
today and we're hoping to get your
reaction later as well so thank you both
thank you all very much for for joining
us today and we'll see you all in a
short while
well of course uh boris johnson is not
just uh under pressure over the drinks
party this is the front door of downing
street
we'll return to it as soon as he emerges
the latest furore began with revelations
about a downing street garden cheese and
wine event on the 15th of may 2020 where
the prime minister his wife carrie and
the prime minister's principal private
secretary martin reynolds were pictured
that is the party there five days later
mr reynolds who's the gentleman in the
middle of his arm up invited downing
street employees to the bring your own
booze drinks event
later that year on the 13th of november
according to reports boris johnson
apparently gave a speech at a downing
street leaving do
and then on the 25th of november a
treasury spokesperson admitted staff had
an impromptu drinks event at the office
the mirror reports that on the 27th of
november boris johnson gave a farewell
speech to another aide while england was
still in lockdown
an education department event was held
on the 10th of december after reports
that the former education secretary
gavin williamson threw a party
and it was revealed that on the 14th of
december a party attended by the london
mayoral candidate sean bailey was held
at conservative hq
the sunday mirror then published a
picture showing the prime minister with
colleagues at number 10 taking part in
an online christmas quiz
a day later the mirror reported on a
low-key socially distanced gathering
attended by civil servants for the
transport secretary grant shaps's office
and on the 17th of december it was
reported that a gathering was held in
the cabinet office which included a quiz
that claim uh sparked it all though is
the alleged downing street party on the
18th of december that resulted in the
resignation of the prime minister's
spokesperson allegra stratton
so so far the only person to resign uh
over this
possibly somebody who wasn't even at the
party um our political editor beth rigby
is here lovely to see you beth and this
is serious for the prime minister isn't
it today it really is jane and i was
saying in my report last night about
this being a moment of acute political
danger for him and it's
acutely important for him today to put a
really strong performance in his mps are
watching and waiting they're looking at
how he handles it
they want to see what he says
about the party will he explain will he
apologize will he observate and
stonewall that's the thing they're all
watching uh to see what he does
but in terms of the mood of the party i
think there is a growing demand from his
mps that he actually comes clean about
what did or didn't happen hiding behind
sue gray in this investigation has
actually only served to anger mps and
that clip that he gave earlier in the
week when he was asked about this and he
uh smiled slightly some people said it
was a smirk and said well that's up to
sue gray uh mps afterwards said to me
it's just not good enough it's really
upsetting the public and it's all sort
of set in ours and jane i've got um
a few
of the words that some of his mps have
said over the past 24 hours caroline
knocks the chair of the equality select
committee former cabinet minister
said last night to constituents there
are no words that can adequately express
how angry i am tobias elwood told sky
news this morning uh again a former
minister chair of a select committee i
strongly urge the pm to act now to
apologize for number 10's poor judgment
to show contrition and be committed to
responding to sue grade's findings
christian wakeford for bury south said
barry south said how do you defend the
indefensible you can't it's embarrassing
and it further erodes
trust i mean support for the prime
minister uh is very thin at the moment
and he really does need to give a
performance to try and reassure mps
if he can
because he there was there were
obviously always be people within the
conservative party who aren't fans of
boris johnson but perhaps our fans of
the votes he brings uh and and his
leadership style
seeming to be able to sort of bluster
his way through any problem and come out
the other side smelling of roses but
have you sensed
a souring of the mood has that mood
changed yeah i have and actually uh
someone said to me yesterday that even
loyalist to the prime minister of the
prime minister just leaving number 10
now
and that's that's the first time we've
actually seen him since that email
was revealed by itv news inviting a
hundred people to gather in and down the
street on may the 20th and i think the
real issue about this for the prime
minister
and he is someone that gets into
political straight scrapes and gets
himself out of them but the revelation
told to me by eyewitnesses and to many
other journalists that he was actually
at this event in the downing street
garden i was told by eyewitnesses about
40 people
attended and it was clearly a social
event and how do you square that circle
when oliver dowd and the culture
secretary had said just an hour or so
before
in the press conference on the in the
podium in that very street to the public
please only socialize with one person
outdoors
so in this sense as one adviser said to
me uh yesterday the prime minister
really does seem cornered and people are
scratching their heads as to how does he
get out of this can he get out of it or
is this the beginning of the end of his
premiership now that is far from clear
but for people to even be openly
discussing that when this was a man who
at party conference three months ago
looked like
the world king who was a movable from
post just shows how dramatic this fall
from grace has been for boris johnson
and he certainly
didn't look at especially
a bombastic or jolly as he left number
10 did he eyes down cast didn't really
acknowledge the photographers and the
journalists who were all shouting
questions trying to to get a word from
him uh no word forthcoming just straight
into the car
straight out onto whitehall um and down
into parliament square and now into the
house of commons um well all eyes on the
prime minister as he steps up to take
these questions in parliament let's talk
to uh our panel of
mps who are going to join us in advance
and also
afterwards as well give us their
thoughts on what has happened uh in
prime minister's questions and what will
happen stephen hammond conservative mp
for wimbledon and a former health
minister
also liberal democrat chief whip an mp
for fife northeast wendy chamberlain and
fleur anderson shadow cabinet office
minister and labour mp for putney and we
will also return to beth our political
editor and also our panel
of guests uh before prime minister's
question starts and stephen hammond
let's let's bring in you first of all uh
conservative mp uh is it time for boris
johnson to go now
well uh i think it'll be a question of
how he performs today i don't think uh
the first thing is the prime minister
needs to be straight and honest with the
country he needs to tell them what
happened he needs to be clear about
why
he must have known about the invite in
advance why he didn't stop the party and
he needs to show contrition
so that certainly isn't a no from you
you're not you're not saying you know
the prime minister should stay
what i'm saying is the prime minister
needs to start apologizing to the
country because there are a lot of
people judged by my email box and i'm
sure that i'm not alone in that who are
furious and rightly so most of my
constituents that many of my
constituents all follow the rules i
follow the rules my colleagues follow
the rules and it is simply not good
enough for certain people not to have
done so particularly when they were
telling others that they should and i
think the prime minister is a starting
what needs to be absolutely transparent
and honest with
parliament and the country about what
happened and then apologize
and would an apology be enough for you
if it was a a fulsome apology mia culpa
um can he come back from this d do you
think stephen hammond
as a starting point um i think
colleagues will want to be making sure
that he understands
that he needs to
uh i think address a number of other
issues as well um but it would certainly
be as a prerequisite we need a fulsome
apology and an apology that's meant
thanks very much stephen well let's
bring in wendy chamberlain from the
liberal democrats uh not exactly
a resounding vote of confidence from
an mp on his own side uh wendy
chamberlain uh do you though have
confidence in the process that that's
being carried out uh behind the scenes
by sue gray are you confident that we
will get answers
well the first thing i would say is i
find it interesting that stephen has
chosen not to call on the prime minister
to resign because he was quick enough to
call on dominic [ __ ] to resign back
in 2020 for his trip to barnard castle
stephen is part of a number of blue ball
mps um who are you know he's facing a
very thin a majority over the liberal
democrats and our candidate in wimbledon
was told by somebody on the street
yesterday that they would not be voting
for uh the conservatives again as a
result of this so i think steven needs
to take another look at his mailbox in
terms of the process and you know i have
confidence in civil servants carrying
out the correct processes but i think
there is a question about how this whole
process has come about given that
clearly in the first instance it was
simon case carrying out the
investigation
then he had to stand down now we have
sue gray and ultimately the arbiter of
the report that sue grey will produce is
the prime minister himself and that to
me suggests that we are not going to get
the outcome i'm pleased that the prime
minister is coming to prime minister's
questions today he should have been at
the urgent question yesterday where mps
first took the opportunity to question
him about these reports
fleur anderson for labour you're nodding
along there you're you're pleased that
the prime minister's coming today you're
interested to hear what he has to say he
is a survivor though isn't he boris
johnson he's managed to get himself out
of lots of scrapes in the past
um do you think this is one step too far
i think there's a fundamental change
here that people have lost trust with
boris johnson i cannot see what he can
say at prime minister's questions to
actually win back that trust now but uh
even his conservative mps as we've seen
from stephen have put him on notice and
he has so many questions to ask now was
he at that party was rishi sooner cat
that party are there any more parties
have we got more to hear about will he
apologize and that's just the start i
just think he's shown that he's not in
touch with ordinary people and the
decisions he was making back in may 2020
and since then i have shown that as well
so he's got a huge mountain to climb to
win back the trust of british people now
which i i think is fatally broken
stephen hammond that's an interesting
point isn't it because boris johnson
doesn't necessarily have fans throughout
the conservative party but the one thing
that he does have is is fans among the
public and whatever he does it seems
that that
he that he has something about him that
the public like and they vote for him
but
is will this be his downfall in the
sense if if it is he's proven to do
something
that that shows disregard for the public
do you think that the message of boris
johnson in his his winning ways will
abate
i think it's very clear though that what
the public also want is leaders that
they can ha they can trust and
you're quite right the prime minister
has undoubtedly got winning ways and
that was shown in december 2019
but equally those winning ways and that
uh which we've seen from prime ministers
of all political parties can dissipate
if the public don't believe in them and
don't believe they're being honest to
them and i think you know that's that's
why i say the prerequisite today is for
the prime minister make an absolutely
fulsome apology and to be absolutely
transparent about what happened so he
can start or try to start to regain that
trust well um on the subject of public
confidence stephen
sky news have conducted a poll um
whether asking people whether or not the
prime minister should remain in his role
along with yougov uh 56
said he should resign
yes he should resign from his role 56
percent no he shouldn't 27
don't know 17 so a certain amount of
people who aren't quite sure but but
still stephen hammond that the majority
of people that sky and yougov asked said
that he should resign is is the concern
not only the damage that he is doing to
the conservative party for you but but
also the damage that he's doing to to
people's willingness to abide by covert
rules
well it's also a fundamental is it's
more fundamental that it's if the if the
leader of the country is not believed
and not being honest with people it
undermines the whole of the political
process and wendy and fleur and i all
work hard for our constituents
and i have no doubt
and do a great job for our constituents
but the trust in us i mean everybody
will be undermined and therefore i think
it's really important that the prime
minister is absolutely clear with people
today and start and tries to start to
regain that trust that's the way that we
need to move forward
flirty do you agree with that do you
feel that if the prime minister is
diminished it diminishes all mps
well i think steven's desperately trying
to distance himself from the rest of his
party and and putting himself with us um
i think that the conservative party are
now being seen for what they are which
is a a party which is not in touch with
ordinary people and therefore making
decisions about things that really
matter to us about
the waiting lists in the nhs about the
cost of living crisis those are the
things we should be talking about today
and instead we're talking about whether
the our leader and the prime minister is
actually up to making decisions making
morally correct decisions and actually
just setting one set of rules um with
one hand and and doing what he likes
with the other and actually making a
mockery of people so i think it's it's
much more important i think people are
losing faith with the conservative party
over this not with all mps
what what do you feel about that wendy i
mean
has has this hindered your job in any
way has it prevented you from serving
your constituents because you've become
wound up in in all of the the noise
surrounding this story
i think there's no doubt that you know
mps are not the most popular of
public servants and so there is an
overall aspect of that you know people
say then you're all the same i came into
parliament just over two years ago with
a background in other parts of the
public service and and i certainly don't
feel that we are all the same but i
think there has been definitely a
narrative from the conservatives for
some time during coronavirus you just
need to look at it in the chamber in
relation to masquerading that shows that
they feel that they are they are above
the law and i'm sure stephen does work
very hard for his constituents but that
doesn't mean that say that we as a part
of the politics here within westminster
aren't impacted by the behavior of
others and the last time uh the public
were asked about this at the ballot box
was in north shropshire in december and
i was certainly journaling there and
people were making quite clear how they
felt about the prime minister and his
behavior and the fact that he has since
then actually told on truths in the
chamber about those parties
well we shall certainly see
stephen hammond wendy chamberlain and
fleur anderson thank you all so much for
joining us today
as we approach at the start of prime
minister's questions uh well let's
return to our three other guests that we
spoke to a little earlier uh jean
adamson who lost her dad to coronavirus
in april 2020 kg pickett the owner of
beauty salon whose business has been
severely impacted by the pandemic and
also nina ambrose who is a care home
volunteer and lost her dad to covet a
year ago and i said we're going to come
back to you and ask you the same
question really and gene
what is it that you want to hear from
the prime minister today
quite simply but we want the truth
sorry gene we didn't we just had a big
problem with your link there we didn't
quite hear you just just yeah what what
would you like to hear from the prime
minister
quite simply what we require from him is
the truth
we want to hear um
what actually happened
on the 20th of may
without
any excuses
um so transparency is is what we need
so miriam what stephen hammond has said
there about transparency and katie
for you what what are you hoping that
the prime minister will say and do today
um i'm thinking just
uh
a transparent justification an
explanation of
how he could
he he could have gone about about this
party i think
um it's
total hypocrisy uh and yeah i think an
apology is is needed um i don't know
whether he'll be able to even justify it
but we'll see
uh thank you very much katie and nina
what are you hoping for
you know what it's lead by example for
me they led the country morally this is
wrong whether he or members of his party
had
a party it's it's just wrong we need
explanations and like your other two
guests said transparency
well nina katie and jean thank you all
so much it's been really great to hear
your thoughts today thanks a lot for
joining us um let's return to our
political editor beth rigby who is still
with us um
beth
it's about restoring trust isn't it it's
about transparency and apology in
restoring trust according to the mps and
also the other people that we spoke to
today yeah and we've just had it
confirmed now that the prime minister
will make a short statement
uh just at the top of pmq's three four
five minutes where he's going to well
what mps want to see what the members of
the public want to see is this apology
and explanation but wasn't it
interesting when you said to stephen
hammond he's not a fan of boris johnson
he was
one of the remainers that had a very
bruising time during those brexit wars i
should say that but he was very clear
wasn't he when you said is it time for
him to go
he said it depends what he says today
and it just gives you a sense of how
acutely important this statement is it's
definitely the most
important pmq since he became prime
minister it could end up as one of the
most important political moments of his
entire career
but the question is is it enough and i
think the thing that i picked up
yesterday from talking to lots of people
is it's around the issues of what does
sue gray say does the metropolitan
police look at this again
you heard what douglas ross said if it
appears that he has indeed lied
to the parliament that he has not been
truthful
is it tenable to have a sitting prime
minister to do that but ultimately he is
not going to walk as i understand it so
it really does rest on what his
parliamentary party do and whether they
decide that he has become too much of a
liability to carry on and beth we're
looking at the house of commons here on
the right a packed house of commons very
different to what it was like yesterday
when michael ellis spoke about the
tumbleweed on the front bench there
really was and what was what the silence
was deafening yesterday
if you remember when dominic cummings
was in trouble
number 10 managed to corral cajole many
mps to publicly back him and manage to
get people to avoid resigning from
government or polit or or publicly
criticize him at least in the the early
days of that um ferrari
with boris johnson there was silence
yesterday you couldn't find mps to come
and defend him many of them didn't want
to publicly admonish him but
the fact that those benches were empty
was that mps know
the public mood on this they don't feel
that he can
be defended by them and as some of them
have said it's indefensible so they want
to see now how does he respond can he
pull it back can he show them that he
has changed but for some of them it
might be they've taken the decision
it's too far gone that can play out
though over many many weeks
here we go the prime minister is taking
to his feet let's take prime minister's
questions
the prime minister's question
i would like to point out that the
british sign language interpretation
proceedings is available to watch on
parliament live tv we start who start
with premises questions dr james davies
question number one mr speaker
prime minister
mr speaker i know that the whole house
will want to join me in paying tribute
to jack dromey
his working life was devoted to his
trade union members and in recent years
his constituents in birmingham erdington
i was deeply saddened to hear of his
death and my thoughts are with harriet
and the family and all those who knew
him as a friend
mr speaker i want to apologize
i know that millions of people
across this country have made
extraordinary sacrifices
over the last 18 months
i know the anguish that they have been
through
unable
to mourn their relatives unable to live
their lives as they want or to do the
things
they love
and i know the rage
they feel
with me
[Music]
and with the government i lead
when they think that in downing street
itself
the rules are not being properly
followed by the people who make the
rules
and though i cannot anticipate the
conclusions of the current inquiry
i have learned enough to know that there
were things we simply
did not get right
and i must take responsibility
[Applause]
number 10 is a big department
with the gardeners exten as an extension
of the office
which has been in constant use because
of the role of fresh air in stopping the
virus
and when i went into that garden just
after six on the 20th of may
2020
to thank groups of staff before going
back into my office 25 minutes later to
continue working
i believed implicitly that this was
a work
event
but mr speaker
with hindsight
i should have sent
everyone back inside
i should have found some other way
to thank them
and i should have recognized that even
if it could be said technically to fall
within the guidance
there would be millions and millions of
people
who simply would not see it that way
people who suffered terribly
people who were forbidden from meeting
loved ones at all
inside or outside
and
to them and to this house i offer my
heartfelt apologies
and all i ask is that sugray be allowed
to complete her inquiry into that day
and several others so that the full
facts can be established and i will of
course come back to this house and make
a statement
mr speaker this morning i had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today
mr speaker my constituent carol ridgeway
faces eight weeks of stress and worry as
she waits for an urgent appointment at
the local breast clinic in north wales
yet despite the pandemic 85 percent of
patients in england wait only two weeks
for their urgent suspected cancer
referrals
what can my right honourable friend do
to ensure a quality of health care
across britain
prime minister i thank my honourable
friend uh for his question i'm sorry
about the case that he raises of course
health is a devolved matter but i i
thank our nhs colleagues across the
whole of the uk and i point out that the
welsh government will benefit an
additional 3.8 billion of funding this
year uh plus a further 270 million uh to
support the response to coded mr speaker
we don't come to leave the opposition
kirsten
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker can i join with the
comments about jack dromey we will i
think be doing tributes uh in due course
in relation to jack
well there we have it
after months of deceit and deception
the pathetic spectacle of a man who's
run out of road
his defense his defense that he didn't
realize he was at a party
it is so ridiculous
that it's actually offensive to the
british public
he's finally been forced to admit what
everyone knew that when the whole
country was locked down he was hosting
boozy parties in downing street
is he now going to do the decent thing
and resign
well uh mr speaker
it is
bangkok
went i think somebody will be going for
an early cup of tea as well can i just
say
the questions being asked i want to know
the answer your constituents want to
know the app
i don't need any extra help either so
please
prime minister
well mr speaker i i
i i appreciate the uh the the point that
he's making about the the event that i
uh i attended uh i i want to i want to
repeat that
i thought it was a work event and and mr
speaker
i i regret i regret very much i regret
very much that we did not do things
differently uh that evening mr speaker
as i've said and i take responsibility
and i apologize uh mr speaker
but as for as for his uh his political
point i don't think that he should uh
preempt the outcome of the inquiry
uh he will have he will have a further
opportunity mr speaker i hope to
question me as soon as possible
embarrassing
well that apology was pretty worthless
wasn't it
let me tell him why this matters
yesterday in this chamber honourable
members told heart-wrenching stories
about the sacrifices people across the
country were making
this house
and the whole country were moved by the
honourable member for tran strangford
as he talked about his mother-in-law
dying alone
he was following the rules
whilst the prime minister was partying
in downing street
is the prime minister really so
contemptuous of the british public that
he thinks he could just ride this out
mr speaker i i i heard uh the testimony
of the the honorable member opposite and
i and i and i i share i echo his uh his
sentiments it was it was deeply moving
nobody who heard that uh could fail uh
to have been moved and i know that
people up and down the country i made
huge sacrifices throughout this pandemic
mr speaker and i understand the anger
the rage that they feel
the thought that uh
that people in downing street were not
following those rules i i regret
i regret the way uh the event i have
described uh was handled i bitterly
regret it and wish that we could have
done things differently and i have uh
and will continue to apologize for what
we did for mr speaker he must wait uh
for the uh inquiry which will report as
soon as possible
kirsten mr speaker when the prime
minister's former health sector broke
the rules
he resigned yes and the prime minister
said he was right to do so
when the prime minister spokesperson
laughed about the rules being broken she
resigned and the prime minister accepted
that resignation
why does the prime minister still think
that the rules don't apply to him
[Applause]
mr speaker that's not what i've said and
i i understand i understand the point
that he uh that he makes uh i as i've
said mr speaker i uh regret uh the way
things happened on the evening in
question uh and i apologize but if i may
say to him i do think it would be better
if he waited until the full conclusion
of the inquiry until the full facts are
brought before this house mr speaker and
he will then have an opportunity to put
his points again
[Music]
this just isn't working prime minister
no everyone could see what happened it
started with reports of boozy parties in
downing street during lockdown
the prime minister pretended that he had
been assured there were no parties
how that fits with this defense out i do
not know
exactly then the video landed
blowing the prime minister's first
defense out of the water
so then he pretended he pretended he was
sickened and furious
about the parties
now it turns out he was at the parties
all along
can't the prime minister see why the
british public think he's lying through
his teeth
minister it it was what the public think
not one of the members saying
[Applause]
order
odd order and i certainly don't need any
help from around here if somebody wants
to help me they can help someone else
prime minister
mr speaker it's up to the right
honourable gentleman to choose how he uh
conducts himself in this
in this
is place wrong
[Applause]
i say to him i say to him that he is
wrong
uh
he is wrong in what he said in
in
he said what he is wrong in in what he
said is wrong in several key respects
but mr speaker that does not detract
from the uh the basic point that i want
to make today which is which is that i i
accept that we should have done things
differently on that evening i as i as
i've said to the house i believe
that the events in question were within
the guidance and were within the rules
and that was certainly the assumption on
which i operated but can i say to him mr
speaker that he should wait he should
wait uh you know before he jumps to
conclusions mr speaker a lawyer should
respect the the the
inquiry
i i hope that he will wait until the
facts are established and brought to
this house
mr speaker so we've got the prime
minister attending downing street
parties a clear breach of the rules
we've got the prime minister putting
forward a series of ridiculous denials
which he knows are untrue
a clear breach of the ministerial code
that code says ministers who knowingly
mislead parliament will be expected to
offer their resignation
the party's over prime minister
the only question is will the british
public kick him out will his party kick
him out or will he do the decent thing
and resign
[Applause]
mr speaker i i i just want to repeat
that i think that the uh right
honourable gentleman i and i i know that
is it is his objective and he's paid to
try to remove me from office uh mr
speaker i appreciate that and i accept
that but i humbly suggest to him uh that
he should he should wait until the
inquiry has concluded uh he should study
it uh for himself and i will certainly
respond as appropriate and i hope that
he does but in the meantime yes mr
speaker i certainly wish uh that things
had happened differently on the evening
of may the 20th mr speaker and i
apologize for all the misjudgments uh
that have been made for which i take mr
speaker full responsibility here's
starbuck
the prime minister's a man without shame
the public want answers to their
questions
hannah brady's father sean was just 55
when he lost his life to covid he was a
fit and healthy key worker i spoke to
hannah last night prime minister
her father died
just days before the drinks trolley was
being wheeled through downing street
and last year
hannah met the prime minister
in the downing street garden
she looked at the prime minister in the
eye and told him of her loss
the prime minister told hammer he'd done
everything he could to protect her dad
looking back what hannah told me last
night was this she realizes
that the prime minister had parted in
that same garden the very day
her dead her dad's death certificate was
signed
what hannah wants to know is this
does the prime minister understand why
it makes her feel sick
to think about the way that he's behaved
mr speaker i sympathize
deeply with uh with hannah with people
who have suffered up and down this
country uh during the pandemic and i
repeat
that i wish things had been done
differently on that evening mr speaker
and i i repeat my apology for all the
misjudgments that may have been made
that were made
on my watch uh in number 10 and across a
government but i want to to reassure the
people of this country including hannah
and and her family
that mr speaker we have been working to
do everything we can to protect her and
her family and it is thanks to the
efforts of this government uh that we
have the most tested population in
europe with 1.25 million tests being
conducted every day
we've been working to ensure that this
population our country has the most
antivirals of any a country in in europe
and mr speaker it's because of the
efforts of the government of officials
of staff up and down whitehall that
we've driven the fastest vaccine rollout
in
europe uh one of the fastest in the
world and that is the reason mr speaker
that we now have one of the most open
economies if not the most open economy
in europe uh and one of the fastest
growing economy mr speaker in the g7 and
mr speaker whatever the mistakes that
have been made on my watch for which i i
apologize and which i fully acknowledge
that is the work mr speaker that has
been going on in number 10 dining street
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker education is one of
the biggest factors when it comes to
leveling up it's what ensures that
people right across the country have
access to the same opportunities and
it's a key part of my mission to
transform lives in burnley and paddy
with that in mind would the prime
minister work with me to ensure that
bernie becomes the best place to study
whether you're in primary and secondary
school looking for an apprenticeship in
advanced engineering or undertaking a
degree in cyber security
yes i thank my my honourable friend and
we're investing in education up and down
the country and i'm delighted that
burnley college was part of a successful
proposal to become an institute of
technology and that burnley is home to
the growing university of central
lancashire campus making it a fantastic
place to study in lancashire
they did the snp in blackfoot
thank you mr speaker and can i add my
remarks in terms of jack drummy someone
who was a festy fighter for workers
rights and an inspiration to so many of
us across this house for the way that he
conducted himself we will miss him and
condolences to harriet and to the rest
of the family
mr speaker
the prime minister
stands before us
accused of betraying
the nation's trust
of treating the public with contempt of
breaking the laws
set by his own government
a former member of her majesty's armed
forces paul wrote to me this morning
his father died without the love and
support of his full family around him
because they followed the regulations
prime minister
paul said
as an ex-soldier i know how to follow
the rules but the prime minister has
never followed any rules he does what he
wants and he gets away with it every
time
the prime minister can't get away with
it again
will the prime minister
finally
do the decent thing and resign or will
his tory mps be forced to show him the
door
prime minister
well i i thank the right honourable
gentleman but i must
and i i want to offer my condolences to
uh to his constituents who wrote to him
and uh just to remind him of what i've
i've said earlier and with the greatest
respect to him i think that he should
wait until the inquiry has concluded in
blackfoot it's an open and shut case
it's an event that should have taken
place it broke the law prime minister
and what's so galling about that
response is that the prime minister
feels no shame for his actions
the public suffered pain and anguish it
being kept apart from their families all
the while the prime minister was
drinking and laughing behind the walls
of his private garden
the public overwhelmingly think that the
prime minister should resign trust has
been lost and the public will not
forgive or forget
if the prime minister has no sense of
shame
then the tory backbenchers
must act to remove them
they know the damage is done
this weak and contentious prime minister
can no longer limp on the message from
the public is clear
remove this unfit prime minister from
office and do it now
prime minister well
again i just want to uh thank the right
honourable gentleman for his
his political advice which i will take
with a pinch of salt uh since it comes
from the scottish nationalist party uh
but i think that uh most people looking
objectively at what this government has
uh delivered over the last 18 months
would agree uh that ins and i i renew my
uh contrition for the mistakes that have
been made
but we have delivered the fastest
vaccine and the fastest booster rollout
in europe and and the result is that
across our whole of our united kingdom
mr speaker uh we have uh the a record
number of people back in work simon fell
thank you mr speaker on friday i met
with the chief executive of my local
hospital trust the university hustles in
morecambe bay to talk about how they
were managing covid and the impact it
was having on them
the impact is stark they've got about 12
to 15 of their workforce away isolating
and 140 beds that's about 20 percent of
the total blocked because they can't get
people back out into social care in the
community so with that in mind will my
right-hand friend consider reducing the
self-isolation period if it seemed to be
safe to do so down to five days
and also accepting any macro requests
which come through to help get people
back out into the community and into
social care
yes mr speaker well we're certainly
looking at to reducing the isolation uh
period and uh hope to bring you more and
mr speak about that as fast as possible
we'll certainly look at all mapper uh
requests uh but more fundamentally what
we can do to alleviate the pressures uh
in his hospital is to fix the the health
and social care uh divide which is what
this government uh is also doing after
uh a generation of neglect
stephen
uh thank you mr speaker today's apology
is too little too late
if the prime minister was sincere he
could have apologized at any stage over
the past 18 months
rather than waiting until he was found
out
my constituents in north down and people
across the uk feel betrayed by the prime
minister we've had over
1 000
we've over um
150 000 deaths from covet
over the past couple of years we have
seen standards in public life trashed
so for once can the prime minister do
the honourable thing and resign
for the sake of the public health
message and for standards in our
democracy
well mr speaker i i can only repeat what
i've uh said and i i understand uh
the
feelings he has about the effect of this
pandemic on the on this country and i
and i i certainly agree for uh everybody
uh who's died and who's and who has
suffered uh but on his on his political
point uh can i propose that he he waits
uh for the inquiry to report
somewhere
thank you mr speaker i recently visited
my local job center and i'm absolutely
pleased to announce that the adult claim
account is down 28
and the young adult claimant count is
down 40 will the prime minister join me
in thanking all the hard work of this
starbridge job centre for their
dedication to actually achieve these
results and also to contribute to the
job survival that's happening across the
west midlands 61 000 new jobs since
march 2021.
[Applause]
uh yes indeed mr speaker and i i thank
her for for that and i i i it's notable
that the opposition uh don't like to uh
dwell on these on these points but it is
an astonishing fact uh that we have 420
000 more people in work now than before
the pandemic began and youth
unemployment at a record low mr speaker
stephen balder
mr speaker another week another scandal
for this prime minister and he's utterly
shameless government for two years my
constituents made sacrifice after
sacrifice spending time away from our
loved ones missing out and important
life events some paid the ultimate
sacrifice while he parted away
figures released just last night showed
at 97 plus 79 percent of people in
scotland think the prime minister should
step down does the prime minister now
realize that it's clear to all that well
he may not understand to be socially
distant from others there is no doubt
that he is morally distant from the rest
of us across these nations and the best
thing he can do now is go resign prime
minister
mr speaker i thank the uh honourable
member for the snp and i repeat the
point that that i've made earlier on i
don't think that he should preempt or
anticipate uh the inquiry
join morrissey
thank you mr speaker the com valley
regional park runs through my
constituency and the prime ministers
would my right honorable friend join me
in paying tribute to the volunteers who
tirelessly work to preserve this
precious green space and will he work
with me to create better protections for
this park moving forward my minister i i
certainly will i join her in thanking
the wonderful volunteers and uh i will
do what i can to assist her in
protecting this uh beautiful green space
thank you thank you mr speaker on a
different topic to that of my uh writer
and befriend the leader of the
opposition but a related one
last week at prime minister's questions
the prime minister was asked about his
previous claim about
that his previous claims about inflation
were unfounded and in his reply he told
the house he had said no such thing
but within minutes the inevitable
happened and people were watching videos
on social media
saying exactly that so would the prime
minister like to take this opportunity
to correct the record and apologize for
me misleading the house on this matter
that will be individually misleading the
house prime minister
no mr speaker because i immediately said
uh in my answer to the question that of
course you had to be concerned about
inflation uh at all times uh what i what
i said uh i think on on tv was that some
of the some of the predictions then
about inflation had not uh proved uh
well-founded but clearly inflation is a
is a serious risk uh it is going up and
uh you what we need is a strategy to
tackle it and that's what we have
richard drax
thank you thank you mr speaker
my constituent grant bailey went back to
afghanistan in september he disappeared
in december around christmas time
we think the taliban have him
can my writer my friend advise me and
his family whether he knows anything
about this man who has him and what is
being done to get him home
i thank my honorable friend and uh for
raising the case with me uh and i hope i
will organize a meeting for him uh with
the relevant minister as soon as
possible to to establish what we can do
to help grant culture
he's not
apologized mr speaker
for breaking the rules
and breaking
the law
he's sorry
because he's been called
so when
my constituents
were making
unimaginable
unimaginable
decisions
he was hosting
a boozy
party
in downing street
so how does he think he can still
maintain the one
rule
for him
and another
for the rest of us he cannot
and he must resign
[Applause]
mr speaker i refer to the answer i gave
earlier
thank you very much mr speaker
this friday uh my private members bill
bbc license fee abolition
gets its second reading
it will abolish the bbc license fee
and require the bbc to be funded
by subscription in this day and age it's
ridiculous to have a state
broadcaster
it's ridiculous that people are forced
to pay a fee just because they have a
television
and what is totally wrong
that people who believe the bbc to be
institutionally
biased have to subsidize them
mr speaker will the prime minister if
he's free on friday come along and
support the bill
uh mr speaker i have the highest respect
for the uh for the media uh judgment of
my uh my honorable friend and uh though
i i understand some of his strictures
about the bbc mr speaker i would also
say that it is a great national uh
institution uh but i will i will study
what he has to say i will interest
thank you uh mr speaker we've all had
prime ministers that we disagreed with
or we didn't rape but there's never been
one that debased the office in the way
that
[Applause]
he's now forced to lie down in the back
of his car to keep away from
photographers
we all know the prime minister was
sacked from two previous jobs
so can he explain to the house why he
believes that the great office of prime
minister
can be held to a lower standard than
those previous jobs that he was sacked
uh well i welcome the part of the the
point that the honorable makes i i in
this part in the in the partisan spirit
with which i think it was uh intended uh
i i don't agree with him uh but can i
suggest to him respectfully that he
waits until uh the inquiry is concluded
which i hope will be as soon as possible
washing machine manufacturers are
considering installing microfiber filter
systems in all new washing machines
will the prime minister ask his
ministers
will the prime minister ask his
ministers
to look at them
we've got a slight problem some of you
want to catch my eye the longer this
question takes the less other people
will get in alberta
people laughing at plastic pollution
mr speaker
will the prime minister ask his
ministers to look into the viability of
my bill which has cross-party support
and seeks to introduce inexpensive
microplastic filters on all new washing
machines
well i want to thank my honourable
friend for this is a campaign
and i believe that we should tackle
microplastic pollution mr speaker uh and
i i'm glad that defra are looking at the
introduction of legislation uh for
microfiber filters on washing machines
as a cost beneficial uh solution and i
will make sure that my right on defense
secretary for the environment will keep
him informed of of how we're doing
mr brenda
thank you mr speaker
i too wish to join colleagues in paying
tribute to jack drumming
i knew him first
in the early 70s and worked with him on
the grenvik strike
he will be greatly missed
mr speaker
thousands of men and women in
afghanistan supported the nato mission
and they have been abandoned
in six months we will don't have a
credible route to help people out of
afghanistan safely
the most recent update from the fcdo is
directly contradicted by the un
while the fcto claims that from spring
the unhcr will make referrals to
evacuation schemes
the unhcrc own website is very clear
they make no such a reference
mr speaker
is the government creating a kafka sick
system to intentionally fail
those we owe something to or is this yet
an other case of the immaturism and
hopelessness that prioritized penn
farthings pets over human beings
uh mr speaker i believe he does a
serious injustice to the efforts of
local councils up and down the country
uh to look after people coming from
afghanistan and i think he does an
injustice to the efforts of the of the
uk uh we are proud we are proud already
under operation uh pitting to have
evacuated 15 000 people uh from
afghanistan mr speaker we've allocated
286 million in aid in assistance for
people in afghanistan and we are
continuing to offer uh safe passage to
this country from afghanistan hold homes
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
will be aware that eastleigh was formed
as a railway town from producing
locomotives and carriages to building
gliders for the d-day landings easily
has a proud railway heritage given this
pedigree the excellent transport links
and the need to level up the south does
he agree with me that eastley would make
the perfect home for the new
headquarters of great british railways
well mr speaker my my old friend is a
great champion for eastleigh and as i
told the house earlier further details
of the competition to identify the new
great british railways headquarters will
be announced in the coming weeks
eventually mr speaker in my constituency
of stockport the average rent for a
two-bedroom property is an unaffordable
800 pounds and
recently uh in the last 13 years the
rents have been significantly increasing
one constituent contacted me recently
explained that she and her husband who
are in their 70s and suffer from ill
health have just been served with a
section 21 notice after living in the
property for almost 20 years mr speaker
the prime minister's own manifesto
promised a better deal for renters which
included abolishing no fault evictions
so when will he
scrap this practice and reintroduce the
much needed renter's reform bill which
seems to have been kicked into the long
grass
mr speaker the one of the first things i
did when i became prime minister was to
upgrade local housing allowance to so
the people on social rent uh would be
able to afford uh
where they uh live more easily is a key
component of uh tackling the cost of
living mr speaker but what we're also
doing is building record numbers of
homes mr speaker and i was very pleased
to see a huge increase in the number of
people able uh to get the homes that
they need uh but the point that he makes
about renters is also uh very very
important that's why we're tackling the
rights of renters as well
jack bradson thank you mr speaker 56
million through the leveling up 40
million through transforming cities this
is just some of the investment we've
secured
would my writing or friend agree after
decades of neglect this conservative
party is the only party that is leveling
up opportunities in so-called trends
[Music]
prime minister uh well i thank my
honorable friend he is a fantastic
champion for stoke on trent and
uh in addition to all the uh all the all
the things that
we are supporting in stoke-on-trent i'm
delighted to say that uh stoke-on-trent
will become the home to the home office
as well
thank you very much mr speaker i think
this session shows how much of a
distraction the prime minister's
behavior has been i want to ask him that
after a recent survey showed 37
of small businesses felt totally
unprepared for the introduction of
import controls rules of origin and the
upcoming sps checks so will he listen to
the fsb and introduce financial and
technical support to those small
businesses or is he just too busy
drinking in his garden
uh mr speaker i i thank her about what
we are all what we are doing is offering
uh financial and technical support to
businesses and they are responding
magnificently and as we come out of uh
the pandemic we are seeing as i said to
the house earlier on uh record numbers
of people in work and youth unemployment
at a record low less you can't
speaker the motto of england's smallest
county rutland is molten parvo much in
little and never has that been mortared
in the last two weeks the greatest roman
discovery in 200 years and ichthyosaur
the greatest fossil discovery in a
hundred years so will he please support
us to build a new tourism industry and
two heritage museums in rutland to
preserve these amazing discoveries in
our county prime minister
well mr speaker i am abs i'm a dog uh i
i'm longing to uh come and see the this
is extraordinary additions to the
cultural heritage of rutland and i thank
her
in
for drawing it to my attention and i
look forward to making a visit as soon
as i can daniel zeitner mr speaker the
government's flagship green homes grant
scheme collapsed in a one and a half
billion pound shambles at the end of
last year with just 81 vouchers issued
in cambridge and just 85 in the prime
minister's constituency with energy
bills about to go through the roof what
is it about this government that makes
it so peculiarly unable to run a basic
loft lagging scheme
prime minister uh
mr speaker we are we're supporting uh
measures to retrofit homes up and down
the country
and uh in addition uh what we are to in
order to
uh improve the installation mr speaker
but what we're also doing is supporting
people with the cost of their fuel we
will continue uh to do that through the
warm homes discount the fuel the winter
fuel allowance and all the other
payments that we make
thank you mr speaker on welsh freeports
can the prime minister confirm to me and
my honor small constituents that the uk
government is committed to at least one
freeport in wales and he can can he give
an update to the house as to how
discussions are progressing with the
welsh government yes prime minister well
i i i thank my honourable friend i can
tell her that the uh my run and refund
the secretary of state for levelling up
is indeed uh talking to
his counterparts in the welsh government
about establishing a free port in wales
and i urge our friends in the welsh
government uh to uh agree those plans as
a matter of urgency thank you fox roth
thank you mr speaker the government
commissioned that sent to research the
use of health and disability benefits
but has yet to publish the findings its
own protocol for publication states
social research must be released in a
way that promotes public trust
the cost of living crisis is hitting
disabled people hard at a time when many
people were already struggling and it's
surely time to start rebuilding their
trust so will the prime minister commit
today to publishing this research
prime minister
uh mr speaker we'll do everything we can
to support people throughout the uh the
recovery period from uh the pandemic
will we will support disabled people and
continue to increase our our support for
for families up and down uh the country
and she makes her she requests that that
we publish the research we will do so as
soon as we can mr speaker jenkinson
thank you mr speaker and can i thank my
right honourable friend for his
continued support for new nuclear yeah
following the passing of our landmark
nuclear financing bill this week will he
put his weight behind my efforts and
those of my cumbrian colleagues to bring
large and small new nuclear to cumbria
yeah
prime minister i i thank my honourable
friend and uh he is quite right that uh
one of the disasters of the labour
administration uh of the 13 years of
labor was that they allowed a total
collapse in our nuclear power mr speaker
i'm afraid which is one of the reasons
we have a shortage a shortage of energy
and that's why we're investing now in
small modular reactors as well as as the
as the big projects chris
thank you mr speaker so the prime
minister didn't spot
that he was at a social event
that that's the excuse isn't it
come off it
i mean how stupid does the prime
minister think the british people are
yeah
the worst of it is he's already managed
to completely destroy allegra stratton's
career
he's tarnished the reputation of lord
geit
and now he's making fools of every
single mp who cheered him earlier
every single one who goes out on the
radio and television to defend this
shower of shenanigans
would it not be absolutely despicable
if
in the search for a scapegoat
some junior member of staff ends up
losing their job
but he kept his
[Applause]
well
i i'm i'm grateful as ever mr speaker to
uh the the right honourable gentleman i
think a former member of the
conservative party as i uh as i
understand it uh but uh i'm grateful to
him for his party his party political uh
advice i don't i don't agree with him uh
mr speaker i i've come to this house uh
to uh make amends to to explain
to explain
uh
what happened on may the 20th and to
apologize uh but mr speaker i i really
think that uh with all humility i must
ask him to wait
to wait for the
result of the inquiry where he will have
abundant opportunity mr speaker to
question me again and to make his party
political points again but until then mr
speaker i am going to ignore his advice
jonathan
thank you mr speaker
[Applause]
[Music]
hundreds of respondents took part in the
stoke-on-trent north kidsgrove and talk
bus back better survey of which 80 said
they would use the bus more if services
were improved the conservative led stoke
on stoke-on-trent city council has
submitted a fantastic bus back better
bid for 90 million pounds to improve our
infrastructure and our services so will
the prime minister make our day in
stoke-on-trent and announce that money's
coming soon
thank you for this fantastic champion of
stoke contract i also thank him mr
speaker for volunteering to serve as a
teacher again
during the pandemic
a wonderful thing uh to do uh mr speaker
and i will certainly look and see what
we can do to satisfy his request for
more buses in stoke as fast as possible
final question ed davey mr speaker can i
join in the tributes to jack dromey an
outstanding trade unionist and member of
this house
mr speaker after another shameful week
for his government this has been a
shameful attempt to apologize
uh to this house today
so can the minister admit prime minister
explain
why the only person to resign so far for
this scandal is allegra stratton a woman
while he the man who sanctioned and
attended at least one party in 10
downing street still sits in his place
mr speaker advisers advise and ministers
decide
so will the prime minister for the good
of the country
accept that the party is over and decide
to resign yeah
prime minister mr speaker i thank him
for his uh question uh it's it's uh you
know and i i respect the uh the point
that he's making but i must say i i
disagree and i would ask him on the on
the i would ask him to wait and see what
the inquiry says and i will i'll be very
happy uh to talk to him there
we
i'm gonna let people leave before we
start the urgent question
she what
she gave the pin
quite a moment in the commons as the
commons entities at the end of prime
minister's questions there's trust
they're giving the prime minister a sort
of rather reassuring uh uh well squeezed
to the leg uh sort of a pat on the leg
uh let's just listen back to that short
statement from boris johnson ahead of
prime minister's questions
mr speaker i want to apologize
i know that millions of people
across this country have made
extraordinary sacrifices
over the last 18 months
i know the anguish that they have been
through
unable
to mourn their relatives
unable to live their lives as they want
or to do the things
they love
and i know the rage
they feel
with me
[Music]
and with the government i lead
when they think that in downing street
itself
the rules are not being properly
followed by the people who make the
rules
and though i cannot anticipate the
conclusions of the current inquiry
i have learned enough to know that there
were things
we simply
did not get right
and i must take responsibility
[Applause]
number 10 is a big department
with the gardeners as an extension of
the office
which has been in constant use because
of the role of fresh air in stopping the
virus and when i went into that garden
just after six on the 20th of may
2020
to thank groups of staff before going
back into my office 25 minutes later to
continue working
i believed implicitly that this was
a work event
but mr speaker
with hindsight
i should have sent
everyone back inside
i should have found some other way to
thank them
and i should have recognized that
even if it could be said technically to
fall
within the guidance
there would be millions and millions of
people
who simply would not see it that way
people who suffered terribly
people who were forbidden from meeting
loved ones at all
inside or outside
and
to them and to this house i offer my
heartfelt apologies
and all i ask is that sue gravy allowed
to complete her inquiry into that day
and several others so that the full
facts can be established and i will of
course come back to this house and make
a statement
well the prime minister in the house a
short while ago political editor beth
ruby is here we'll get her reaction in
just a moment but first just ahead of
prime minister's questions we spoke to
some of those whose lives and
livelihoods were deeply affected by
coronavirus boris johnson has apologized
to them and the british public at large
so let's get their reaction
on what they heard uh so thank you so
much for all staying with us gene katie
and nina um
gene to you first of all gene adamson
you lost your dad cleo during covet you
said in advance of prime minister's
questions that you wanted to hear the
truth about what happened without
without excuses did you get that
i'm afraid i haven't got that at all i
haven't taken
any comfort or solace away from
boris's uh i'm going to call it a
performance
um in pmqs
he
continues to wriggle
and to try and get away
get out of this
and save his own hide and that was very
clear to me
um
the fact that he's saying that he didn't
know
it was a
party he believed it to be a work event
i mean
these lies that he continues to peddle
it
you know it's just so offensive and so
insulting
um you know what we have
here is
more
obfuscation
smoke and mirrors
and
he continues to lie his way into trouble
and then tries to lie his way out of it
um i'm afraid i'm not at all impressed
and i don't feel
any sense of
comfort uh uh from from from that um
apology that performance um just now
well that's pretty clear what you think
gene um what about katie pickett katie
to remind our viewers has a beauty salon
and had to follow a huge number of
workers really struggled financially
homeschooled the kids and you wanted an
explanation um
do you feel that you've got that
explanation from him
no i think
obviously i'm pleased that he came forth
with an apology
however i think
um he still can't justify
um
the damage is already done i feel like
he just kept swerving
the answer
um and also it's so hypocritical to say
he thought he was within the rules
uh i mean what rules were there
that that people were having work events
anyway
we wasn't even allowed to go to work
so um i think he realizes he said a
statement um saying all of the
misjudgments that he had made
so um i think he does realize but i just
feel like he's trying to buy himself
some time um by constantly referring to
the inquiry um and hoping that you know
all is forgotten and we're on to the
next big news story so yeah certainly um
we had an apology but i don't feel we
had a
justification um in any sense of the
word
okay uh nina ambrose nina you
volunteered in a care home you lost your
dad roger to covert as well um you said
that you were hoping he would lead by
example uh has he done that for you
today
nina i think you might be muted can you
unmute yourself nina
it's okay
you know you want him to lead by example
do you feel he has
yeah my issue here is that he just never
owns it or denies it you either did it
or you didn't do it
just let us know you know we're not just
talking about something that's sort of
gone wrong here casually we're talking
about
thousands upon thousands of deaths and
people stuck to rules if you didn't do
it and they go with this inquiry and he
is guilty i'm sorry but
some serious action needs to be taken
okay do you accept his apology do you
feel that what you heard today was an
apology nina
um being honest no i don't i don't feel
it's an apology i feel
it's kind of biding time
okay well we really appreciate your time
and and for talking to us and explaining
your stories and then giving your
reaction afterwards nina ambrose katie
pickett and gene adamson thank you so
much really appreciate it
so that's the reaction um of uh some sky
news viewers people who are affected by
covid uh beth rugby our political editor
is here um
certainly not a huge amount of of warmth
from from those three ladies about what
they heard um
the prime minister said right at the end
there he came to this house to make
amends to explain and apologize
is it enough to save his skin
well i have to say from the messages i'm
getting from mps uh
they're not particularly satisfied
either it seems when you strip back what
boris johnson actually said that he was
apologizing for how it looked he said
with hindsight i would have sent
everyone back inside he confirms that he
went to this event which he then
maintained in that statement
was a work event that he thought
technically fell within the guidelines
so he is keeping that as his essential
line of defense for the grey inquiry
look this fell in the guidelines whilst
also acknowledging and apologizing for
how it actually looked to the public and
you saw there how labour seized on it
people saying you're taking the british
public for fools uh kirsten was saying
that you're lying through your teeth and
actually what was really interested in
this particular prime minister's
questions was
kirstama has been asked repeatedly over
the past two years on various occasions
should boris johnson resign he never
went there and today he bit the bullet
and he said will you resign
when i went back to his team and said
why now why this moment their view is
that whether conservative mps decide to
move against boris johnson or not this
is a prime minister who's a busted flush
that he might try and maintain this this
was a work event
but the public have seen the email that
was leaked to itv news about bring your
own boos they know that people were
attending this gathering in the garden
and they now know that the prime
minister attended that during the height
of that lockdown uh last or may 2020 um
some reaction from conservative mps one
of them saying to me we're in a really
tricky place that is not someone that is
disloyed to boris johnson i should add
and another mp saying to me uh that it
appears that he has now set up the sue
gray inquiry as the make or break moment
for his premiership so he's perhaps
brought some more time kicked the can
down the road but my view doesn't change
that he is still in acute political
danger at the moment
one of the points that somebody made on
twitter just a short while ago you know
his his uh saying that it was a work
event and that he went out there to
thank his staff um
if you want to hold an event to thank
your staff maybe you should buy them a
drink not not ask them to bring their
own which which sort of
throws there's more doubt on actually
you know how do you know it's a party
and how do you know it's a work event
and this might come out in the in the
gray inquiry because when this uh
email emerged by it was paul brand uh
from itv on monday we knew that there
had been an event because dominic
cummings the former uh chief of staff or
or key advisor to the prime minister had
been tweeting and writing a blog about
it
but the actual email was the hard
evidence uh about the details of the
event now that was sent to a hundred
people and and and those uh who were
involved in number 10 said to me that at
the time people raised
the alarm bells over this and said hang
on a minute you this looks really bad
this looks like a social event and i was
told by
one figure that it was clearly raised
that it shouldn't go ahead i think
dominic commons has actually tweeted
about this in the past few minutes as
well and still it went ahead so the idea
that the prime minister believed that it
was a work event in the guidelines which
is what he has said in the commons
today
has been disputed by people who
at the time saw that email and and i
mean if 100 people invited about 40
turned up a good number of staff kept
away
from that event this would all come out
in the grey inquiry
but the prime minister there
offering an apology
but for how it looks not what actually
happened and i imagine that many mps
will not be happy with that and the fact
of the matter is that whatever this
inquiry fan finds out he has admitted he
was at an event that he shouldn't have
been at uh in breach of the coveted
rules so
it's clear that he has breached the
regulations um
we've we've got calls for there's a
resignation from all of the opposition
parties both labour lib dems and and the
uh s p all
called for him to go um as you say it's
the first time the labour party have
have done this
but the fact that they have all these
calls have all come together and the
fact that he has admitted wrongdoing um
is there a case for the met to get
involved now
well the met is having a look at this
again they confirmed on monday night
that in light of that email
and other evidence that they were now
looking at this again
and they will have to take a decision
about whether or not they decide
that they will look at this now i think
in the past they said we're not going to
look at retrospective potential
covid breaches but that is a big live
question certainly is beth thank you
very much well that was prime minister's
questions coming up at one o'clock we'll
get more reaction to what has happened
in the house of commons over the last
hour and boss johnson's apology at the
beginning of pmqs
[Music]
[Music]
you